unless you've spent quality time on the
International Space Station this is
probably not of you you are super
familiar with this is the east coast of
the United States that's New York down
there in the lower right and it's a band
of light all the way up through
Washington DC those cities are shining
like jewels highways are traced by webs
of light and all of that light is super
photogenic but there's a problem that
light is meant to be illuminating our
sidewalks and our streets and our houses
instead it's actually going up into the
sky and out into the universe where it's
not doing any of us any good when I see
photos of this of the earth I see
environmental catastrophe
those aren't jewels those are tumors I'm
an astronomer so it's really no surprise
probably to anyone that I've always
loved the night sky
I forgive a walking cliche but when I
was growing up in Minnesota one of my
favorite things to do on a summer
evening was grab my old raggedy ANNs
sleeping bag and take it out into a
field behind my house where I would
spend hours looking at the night sky and
to do this I had to brave not only the
darkness but also swarms of mosquitoes
and my sleeping bag really didn't smell
very good but there was one particular
star that I would look for a night after
night and then I would play this game
where I would try to focus on that star
so intensely that everything else would
fade from my view and that single star
would be all that I could see I could
only ever hold onto that focus for a few
fleeting moments but when I did I felt
this deep sense of connection to the
universe and almost
almost a sense of vertigo like I was
gonna fall into space and when this
happened I know this sounds kind of
ridiculous but I would simultaneously
feel like unfathomably and significant
and also kind of weirdly important that
star I looked to night after night it's
called Vega Vega is the brightest star
in the constellation Lyra which is not
coincidentally the name of one of my
dogs but this experience is being lost
my favorite constellation Lyra this is
what it would look like from Manhattan
for people who live in urban and
suburban environments if they go outside
at night and look up instead of being
awestruck by the majesty of the universe
they see pretty much nothing
these unremarkable completely blank
night skies of course are due to all of
the light we produce at night those very
same lights we see all the way from
space are shining up into the atmosphere
or they bounce around and create this
featureless smog of light and that
featureless smog of light has a name
it's called light pollution as an
astronomer I can actually tell how bad
light pollution is by the brightness of
stars I can see in the sky and it turns
out that when you're trying to unlock
the secrets of the cosmos it's really
helpful to be able to see the cosmos and
truth and this light that we're trying
to detect is coming from millions or
billions of light years away and so it's
generally pretty faint and as an
astronomer I fight with this every day
to do my job and I have to tell you it
is a really big problem but the problem
is far worse than just losing some
whimsical ability to gaze at the Stars
for example countless plant and animal
species are affected so we could talk
about sea turtles or
pollinators or any of these super
important species that are also cute
instead I want to talk about these
quietly unassuming dog whelks you may
have seen them around and not given them
really a whole lot of thought but
they're pretty cool so in an entire year
a dog walk will rarely move more than
about 10 meters that means that when
they are attacking their prey they can
hit this brisk pace of about a
millimeter an hour and this works out
okay because they attack things like
barnacles
so these dog whelks live in the
intertidal area of coasts where it turns
out they're a pretty key part of the
ecosystem not only are they one of the
most dominant invertebrate invertebrate
predators but other animals like crabs
and birds think they're pretty tasty
so that leaves these poor snails and a
kind of precarious situation because if
they go too low in the water then their
crabs are a threat but if they come out
of the water too far birds are gonna
have a feast why is an astronomer
telling you about dog whelks I asked
that myself because their behavior is
impacted by light pollution for example
if dog walks are subjected to artificial
light at night they're about twice as
likely to stay under the water with a
predator and that puts them at increased
risk and it's not like they can make a
speedy escape and so these and the other
issues because they literally move at a
snail's pace if a population is wiped
out it can take decades to replenish and
that in turn affects the rest of their
ecosystem and the other species like the
birds and the barnacles and the crops so
this is just one small and slimy example
of how light pollution can unleash a
cascade effect on an entire ecosystem
virtually every species that has been
studied to date is impacted by light
pollution and that includes humans so
let's talk about us you are probably not
surprised to hear that light pollution
can affect your ability to sleep well at
night but you might be surprised to hear
that light pollution is linked to
obesity in fact in a recent study they
found that light pollution contributed
to over 70% of the obesity rates in 80
countries more than that light pollution
actually contributed about the same
amount to excess weight as eating junk
food and it gets worse for people who
are subjected to significant amounts of
artificial light at night there are
about 50 percent more likely to get
breast cancer
and in fact light pollution is
correlated with types of cancer across
the board and in controlled lab
experiments there's a direct link
between increased artificial light at
night and a rate of tumor growth you
might be wondering how normal light
could possibly impact cancer rates it
likely all comes down to the super
important hormone called melatonin which
we have evolved over millions of years
to produce on a day/night cycle or a
circadian rhythm what happens is that
when light impacts the retina at the
back of our eye at night it can disrupt
melatonin production and when melatonin
production is disrupted a whole chain of
other chemical processes are affected
and that includes estrogen production
and when we throw this chemical balance
out of whack really bad things can
happen in fact things are so bad that
the International Agency for cancer
research has said that disrupting the
human circadian rhythm is a probable
carcinogen also for fun I want to let
you know that light pollution has been
linked to let's see headaches anxiety
depression diabetes cardiovascular
disease and the list goes on but maybe
you don't care about your health we're
all gonna die anyway you might as well
die in a brightly lit room the fact that
you're laughing about death is kind of
amazing you might still care about money
the money that's spent on that wasted
light and I mean just the light that's
going out into the universe and not
doing us any good it's three billion
dollars a year that's enough money to
build like a thousand utility-grade
windmills or fund the entire DC public
school system for over two years or this
is my favorite cuz I really want one but
I can't afford one by 30,000 Tesla Model
X SUVs
and that includes the electric car Tax
Credit and then there are the
existential costs I don't have any data
on how losing touch with our place in
the cosmos impacts us but I believe that
this probably impacts our humanity more
than any of the other scary statistics I
can share with you and that's getting
worse with time
the amount of light pollution is
doubling roughly every 35 years that
means that within the next decade
virtually the entire eastern half of the
United States will be perpetually
brighter than Twilight and there's
another issue with light pollution the
problem is way worse than we can see
with our own eyes our eyes have evolved
to just detect this tiny range of the
full spectrum of light all of this other
light that we can't see this invisible
light also has a pollution problem
mostly it's from modern technology
things like cell phones or car to car
radar or now apparently we need
appliances that can talk to each other
all of this modern technology is putting
out strong signals that can completely
swamp these exceedingly faint light
we're trying to detect from the rest of
the universe outside earth which is for
the record is most of the universe and
then there are satellites satellites are
a problem at both visible and invisible
wavelengths a host of private companies
have plans to deploy tens of thousands
of satellites into Earth orbit where
they will not only outnumber and
literally outnumber the visible stars in
the sky well also beaming invisible
light back to earth so for astronomers
like me who use invisible light to study
the universe it's gonna be like staring
at the Sun and trying to see a birthday
candle behind it all right I want to be
clear that there's nothing inherently
wrong with any of this modern technology
right with cellphones or satellites or
car radar I'm not sure about kitchen
appliances
I haven't broken down and gotten it up
and that talks to my cell phone yet and
I use lights at night like everybody
else but here's the thing some problems
in the world like we've heard about
today and you'll hear more about are
overwhelming and they seem intractable
visible light pollution is not one of
these problems this is actually stupidly
simple okay so here are five super
simple things you can do don't use
lights brighter than you need to don't
use lights when you don't need them
those lights you're using make sure
they're shielded down so they're not
shining up into the sky and let's talk
about LED lights if you have a choice
don't buy the blue ones look for words
like warm white if you buy LEDs with
words like natural light or daylight
that's like saying you hate space
and finally you could advocate for this
even in your local community find out if
there's a lighting code and whether it
could be made more night sky friendly or
dare I say you could even advocate at
the federal level by politely asking our
federal officials some of whom may be
here to please not auction off our view
of the invisible universe to the highest
bidder to pollute at will which is
actually what happens now like a good
professor I have homework for you if you
have never seen a truly dark night sky I
want you to go out and experience one
for yourself because if you don't you
don't know what you're missing and you
don't know what humanity is losing thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]